[Music]
as you know in the stand-up comedy world
sometimes somebody another comic likes a
joke a viewer and without even asking
just starts using it yeah did you ever
experience that do to st. Louis told a
joke and me and a bunch of other
comedians seen him and and the comedian
I was wit was we was with a bunch of
people and only knew two of the people
of the ten that we was with then I told
him I said I do distilling my joke and
after the show him I confront him and we
went up to him after the show and I was
like you stole my joke and he was like
no I did and I was like yes you did and
this dude behind him pulled a gun out
and I just was like oh they got guns and
I ran but the dude that put the gun out
was with us
you ran away from a guy who was backing
you up yes
yeah listen baby are you with us
I was like what tell them thank you
[Laughter]
this is how you run I run like this and
then I wash my socks
I'll walk like this no one should be
pulling guns out about stupid joke first
of all that's the wrong level now I want
you to do it now yeah well you know
those the places that be yet yeah I know
what you're talking
we you and I went on this tour Andy and
myself and you went on a tour like seven
years ago now and the band and we had
this great really fun time going around
the country but I remember one night
specifically we're all waiting for you
to leave to go to the next city and
we're waiting and we're waiting and
we're waiting and we don't know where
you are and you show up and it's because
the night before you drank every little
tiny bottle is that right yes in the
liquor cabinet and a minibar
minibar and then when you were done you
saw how much that cost
yes and so you wanted to do what I went
to the store to buy a whole bunch of
those bottles to restock
[Applause]
everything but the almond Snickers so
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
good time yeah there were a lot of
almond milk that same night not as cool
we found a picture of you and actually
this I think this is on your site but I
hadn't seen it before
this is a picture of you as a kid you've
got an amazing that is the most insane
afro it's I don't know what my momma was
thinking but it was cool yeah I look
like that I look like the black painter
what's that painter does on TBS oh yeah
yeah yeah alright yeah ok believe you
pulled that picture but I got people
that work here too
I work here everybody work I got I got a
picture you pull it up what's that wait
don't show up it Oh
shocking I couldn't get a girlfriend for
so long but yeah look at that overbite
special cold-blooded seminar premieres
Saturday June 20th at midnight on Comedy
Central and an album will be available
on June 28th Dion we're all so happy for
you you've earned everyone
[Applause]
you